you
hi everyone is Gerry let's have a look
at the game that was played in 1967 this
was held in Tunisia at the Sioux Center
zonal on the white end Bobby Fischer and
he's paired against Alam sure in Myanmar
Suren player who won the Mongolian chess
championship in 1965 earned his
international master title in 1966 and
he'd go on to win the Mongolian chess
championship three more times 1980 81
and 82 so let's dive in and see how this
one played out
it appears that we're looking at a
French defense but after d3 it's clear
white is aiming for a Kings Indian
attack system pretty much a universal
system you're seeing here for the white
side could pretty much go for these very
moves against anything black does to
start the game establish a pawn on e4
and d3 and deploy the pieces as such so
same sides castles this is where things
are now cut in half basically the board
is cut in half after E 5 white will be
looking to play on the Kings side and
black on the Queen so the first moment
to really speak of is this one right
here after a 4 there will still be games
where you see Knight H 2 maybe Knight
III or the move in the game a3 a3 in
short and many things you could point
out about a3 but the one I see the one
that sticks out to me most is a3 ensures
that the c2 pawn will retain some
potential some potential to contribute
to the center y can at some point fight
for the d4 square or even the d5 square
since a3 is in
how is this may be different if a3 is
not played in this position in white
carries on with let's say drifting the
minor pieces towards the kingside this
would allow black to play a3 and now
this pawn basically freezes White's C 2
and D 3 structure if ever a C pawn
advance 1 or 2 steps this pawn is always
knocking it out so a 3 in the game be
take saying B takes a Knight a5
and Knight e3 so I pointed out earlier
Knight to e2 93 is far more aggressive
you know from h2 it is only eyeing up
one square III it also eyes up g4 but
also white has this potential to play as
I previously pointed out this c4 advance
this can factor and you can see the
knight on e3 coordinating very well with
the c-4 advance trying to have an
influence on the d5 square
so from here Bishop a6 white is gearing
up for some c4 advance Bishop h3 there's
different tactics you have to be
familiar with on the black side now that
the bishop is pointing at e6 there's
possibilities for a capture on d5 with
an e6 so for example if black routinely
just makes a queen move connecting rooks
there's already a tactical shot Knight
takes d5 and then you could push hitting
the night hitting the Queen you'll get
the material back and this position is
cracking open on the Kings side and
guess who's not there to help defend
these guys are committed to the Queen
side so something to note stay clear of
the c7 square for sure and from here
black parries this idea of a capture on
d5 with these six by giving the knight a
shove
so it goes back f1 Knight b6 square
that's now made available after this
last push is d5 so that's what black is
angling for Knight g5 Knight d5 Bishop
d2 this Bishop is doing a very good job
in not only negating the knight but
tying down the Queen now has a role
watching over the knight and notice the
white pieces are intersecting on e6 a
tactic is being lined up some sacrifice
is being lined up on this square so
trying to defend it well okay it just
drops the knight you can't do that this
pressure is too much on e6 black decides
to take the knight out big decision if
you're doing something different with
let's say rook to b8 this is a problem
because of the sacrifices on e6 and then
you could take on a5 notice the queen is
overloaded in this very position has to
watch over now both knights and whites
going to get the material back Bishop
takes Knight Bishop takes Knight white
would be up to pawns in short this is
pretty serious it's an intersection on
e6 so the knight is taken out bishop
recaptures now if there's one color
complex black has to be on lookout for
it's the dark squares doesn't have a
dark square bishop around white does and
there's also this pawn on the f6 square
so these are critical squares around the
black king so from here Queen d7 Queen
h5
and rook to c8 so this is not only
preparing a/c for advance but also
opening up the f8 square for the Queen
it's important to recognize that white
is ready to do something against the g7
square and the Queen will be around to
help secure the g7 post so from here
it's 92 and this is where black now goes
astray in the game Knight c3 is played
the computer suggests to place c4 to
justify let's say this rook see a move
open up the C file have the bishop and I
have an influence on the c4 square on
the d3 square
c4 is not played here Knight c3 and now
in comes what move first pop-quiz of
this game what move did Fischer play
next
feel free to pause the video okay in the
game we have Bishop f6 so highlighting
the fact that the knight is no longer
around watching over f6 that's let's say
the weakness of one of the weaknesses of
blacks last move the knight on c6 stands
on a secure square but it's kind of
not connected with any other black piece
so it's in a way just out of play it's
not really doing too much from the c3
square so the issue here with capturing
the bishop like in the game ends up
dropping the Queen back but if the
bishop is captured this would no this
would not be any good because of a
recapture and now the Queen's sneaking
into g7 is too difficult to parry how do
you defend against this if King to h8
there's a nice move here one more pop
quiz thrown your way
what would white have in this position
there's multiple good moves but would be
a good move in this position for white
feel free to pause the video okay a good
move here is Bishop f5 the only way to
stop the main threat is to take the
bishop but now we see this thorn pawn
rook a seven can follow rook takes pawn
rook g7 can follow and now black will
have to give up the Queen and the tap
and the attack simply continues white is
winning you can't take the bishop
cleany a is the best move and from here
we have 94 pawn takes Bishop of course
we're recapturing with the fork now so
what we have is g6 this is seriously
weakening the dark squares there's no
there's no turning back after the g6
move one of the better moves is
considered well at the moment maybe
given more time it'll change its mind
computers pointing out something crazy
like 9b 3 and then there's some
sacrifice on g7 and there's an attack
like this Queen h6 lining up Knight f6
this is winning for white okay we don't
have this crazy move Knight b3 g6 in the
game and now this is setting up a
wonderful finish let's see how this is
prepped first Queen g5 Knight takes
Knight rook takes c4 too late at this
stage the attack is just way too strong
there's only one defender for the black
king and it's not the greatest defender
Queen is really no match for two bishops
a queen and a rook these guys are not
contributing the minors are not
contributing so from here h5 pawn takes
pawn rook age 4 by this point black
needs some defense of the 7th rank so
rook a7 why do I say some defense of the
7th rank is needed if black just
continues to pick up material with pawn
takes pawn this is a nice sequence to be
familiar with white can take on g6 so in
the game rookies heaven was played but
if pawn takes pawn white can play pawn
takes pawn if they recapture with the H
pawn that's me
and if you take with the F pawn white
can smash through with this sacrifice
and then give me with the Queen and
Bishop on the g7 square so that's the
tactical sequence black is defending
with this next move rook a7 preparing to
me pawn takes pawn with F takes and the
rook is there the King doesn't have to
recapture from here Bishop g2 and we
have pawn takes pawn this is setting up
a wonderful finish now if you'd like to
go ahead pause the video what sequence
did Fischer go forward with next okay in
the game it is not pawn takes pawn in
fact this would be winning for black
because black is there to recapture and
the defense is there we're going to
shortly see the point behind White's
last move Bishop g2 the winning idea
here
Queen h6 only one way to stop the maid
on g7 Queen f8
more pop quiz in case you didn't get it
one move ago what would white do in this
position feel free to pause the video
okay here we go
one more move and black resigns Queen
takes h7 game over
black resigned here it's me in two moves
the Queen must be captured this would
lead to pawn takes pawn double check if
the King goes to g8 that's me and if the
King takes the pawn we're seeing the
point behind Bishop g2 Bishop efore is
now available for checkmate this is a
very nice sequence to be familiar with
because I've seen I've had plenty of my
own games occur where you know you're
trying to do something along the h-file
you have some battery your opponent
takes a step up one way or the other
with a major piece preparing to capture
away from the center in order to open up
that seventh-ranked defense you'll
notice something here the patients with
this tension there's a reason to keep
that tension for a little bit
capturing too early you open up the
defense and the game can easily turn but
maintaining the tension in this case
allowed for a wonderful tactic Queen
takes h7 double check and mate next but
this is as far as it got in this one
Queen h7 and black resigned anyhow as
usual feel free to leave any feedback to
this video in the comment section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye
you